[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
happy thursday this really is march
madness in the world of basketball there
were double-digit upsets in the
tournament by underdog schools and now
underdog franchises
in the nba are shooting their shots with
double-digit trades today
welcome to the group chat presented by
fanduel you're watching live on the
bluetooth report out my name is cabbie
richards and even though she's 100 years
younger
than sister jean she's equally spicy our
wonderful betting expert is kelly
stewart and with more immaculate vibes
in a shade jojo's alexander
tunnel walk that is greg ivory
remember the the group chat is 24 7
at all times live in the bleacher report
app under the community tab
under sports betting so you can tap in
with us after the show
to continue all that heat so coming up
we have the trial of the century
stewart versus ivory and you guys will
be the jury i can't wait to get to that
each week we use greg's sunset vibes
to bet on the 3x2 the fastest and the
most
bankable bet in the history of sports
it is quite simply will there be two
three-pointers
in the first three minutes of the game
super simple
uh we offered it to you on thursdays but
since it's been we've been
hammering it so hard fanduel's like yo
we need to give this to you on tuesday
so now we have
three by tuesdays last three by tuesday
you guys voted for new orleans versus
portland
and salute to lonzo ball and cj mccollum
because they hit we hit take a look
yes sir ingram spread the
floor lonzo ball work the high pockets
get down
green dot yes sir yes sir and i think
this is cj's first game back too
good to see him just from range
[Applause]
you know a nice pass from dave yo dame
dropped a 50 piece too it was just
crazy uh today we asked you on twitter
which
game is the better 3x2 opportunity
portland versus miami or the
philadelphia 76ers
versus the lakers we put this out on
twitter
the early results are in you guys are
leaning
portland versus miami with 74
of the vote g-money tap in with your
army and ask them how they're feeling
about the three by two options cabbie
kelly let me tap in with the squad
what's up man i see all y'all in the
comments i see everybody in the comments
uh
what i need you guys to do is tell us
which 3x2 are you riding
we got portland miami we got the lakers
philadelphia which one should we ride
which one should we ride
kelly which one do you think we should
ride which way are you leaning
i like portland miami as well and it's
not all that often i like to go with 70
74 of our audience but i think they're
right here
the lakers defense even without lebron
or anthony davis is just too
good and that scares me here for this
quick hitting
prop bet of sorts that we created i like
miami
and portland i think dame tyler hero
maybe cj
maybe duncan robinson somebody's going
to come in clutch for us
let's hope it gets it done unlike last
week where
the audience liked one side i like the
other we're in step lock today
we are in lockstep i like portland too
they're a top 10 three-point shooting
team
and uh like you said you know dame cj
tyler hero until even though tyler hero
is in a sophomore slump
maybe because he didn't get traded today
he's got some renewed confidence and
some
renewed um uh self-assurance that he'll
he'll he'll drop one of these
three-pointers so
i like portland and miami versus uh the
the sixers and the lakers
g-money where are you leaning for our
three by two cabbie before i get to
where i'm leaning
let me tap in with the the fans
uh you guys know what this is this is
the handy dandy ipad and this is how
you get your hoodies let me get into
these comments cabbie
i got chris12c he's rocking with tyler
hero
and the miami heat shout out to you
chris uh you are walking away with a
hoodie
uh j321 says portland miami
shouts out to you j321 you're walking
away with a hoodie uh
road tied roll tide is back row ties
rocking with the lakers
he's rocking with the lakers jj ram 13
3x2 is gonna pay my uh
pay my stake for tonight shout out to
you j.j brown we are going to get you
rich
we are going to get you rich pat
bonninelli pat boninelli
uh he said that they're both for cashing
shout out to you pat
everybody i said you're walking away
with a hoodie i just want you to know
that
but if i was if i had to decide between
the two games
you do have to decide because we're
betting money on these tonight
i i i got a ride i got a ride with
portland and
miami i gotta ride with portland miami
reason being
there's a bunch of shooters all over the
court kathy they're they're shooters
everywhere on the court and uh i'm
rocking with them i'm rocking with them
all right so make sure to check out br's
socials to get the link from fanduel
for the odds boost uh and um you know
someone's calling because they want to
get on that
get in on that too so yeah you're with
us the three by two
um that bet is hitting but unfortunately
you know in the nba we lost
we're we lost lebron james for a couple
of weeks with an injury we've lost
joel embiid for a few weeks for it with
an injury it might take a few weeks to
resolve the tension
between kelly and greg uh but in the
meantime the brooklyn nets
have been scorching the nba winning 16
of 19 games
and have planted themselves on top as
the betting favorites
to win the nba championship these are
the latest odds offered by
fanduel brooklyn nets on top at plus 280
the lakers and the clippers two and
three plus 300
plus 550. g-money are you seeing a bunch
of new nets fans or new nets activity in
the comments
no i'm actually not seeing that cabbie
i'm seeing a bunch of team greg in the
comments
if i'm being honest if i'm being honest
that's what i'm saying who was calling
team greg yeah yeah that i guess that's
who was calling they were calling uh
saying that i needed my money like last
week but
we're going to talk about that any
weapons when you still live with your
parents you got a house phone that rings
in the middle
man just putting a dude on blast and
we're supposed to keep some things in
the family
that is a burn right there it is okay
hey it's okay but let me talk to the
audience let me talk to the people
let me talk to the people kelly uh here
we go
get in the comments tell me who you
think is going to win the nba
championship who would you put a bet in
on
kelly i know you've been on the jazz do
they still have
value uh currently right now value is
relative right
i do want everybody to kind of know
we'll use this as a little learning
lesson here the teams at the top the
brooklyn nets for example
doesn't necessarily mean that's who the
bookmakers think is going to win
that's just who their liabilities are
highest on so they're saying
here we're gonna put up a bad number on
the brooklyn nets hopefully nobody else
bets them because
we've got all the brooklyn nets money we
want so they're going down the list
looking to attract more money the lakers
eek
yikes right now you cannot bet this
lakers team
anthony davis is still not back i hope
he's going to be back in the next couple
weeks for this team's sake
lebron we know is out four to six weeks
so this is a tough one
i think that the jazz will win the
western conference finals
if they can do that then you can find a
hedge opportunity
in the finals versus whoever comes out
of the east
that's how you want to make your futures
bet i do think there is a little bit of
value left on the jazz not much i mean
this team was 35 to one two months ago
and now eight
eight and a half to one is not exactly
ideal but i do think
that you can cash a winning ticket with
this team out of the west which means
you can head
in the finals they're still the best
team in the nba and nobody's talking
about them they're absolutely
underdogs uh but salute to kelly with
that uh a tomorrow eight plus 850
whoever's gonna jump on
as kelly mentioned the lebrons the
timetable for his recovery is estimated
between four to six weeks
so if you like the lakers maybe this is
the time you wait
to get a better number longer odds and
then jump in on the futures
i've got a philadelphia 76ers ticket
they're still plus 1200
jojo's going to be back in a couple of
weeks they're the best team in the east
for now uh so i feel confident with the
sixers because once jojo's back in the
middle
and the shooters surrounding them i
think they've got a shot to win
uh this year's nba championship gmoney
are you still on the brooklyn nets or
why do you still believe in the brooklyn
nets as your future's pick
cabbie i mean is this really even the
question they have superstars
all around kevin durant
james harden kyrie irving with the
sprinkle of blake coming off the bench
deandre jordan joe harris come on cabbie
i can see 2015 bro this isn't how many
minutes is blake griffin actually going
to get
oh this is a serious question all we
need all we need is
is is a couple you know just a couple
minutes a couple spurts
you saw his first game he's not even
dunking bro my guy's
laying the ball he he dunked this what
do you mean he dumped in the last game
he was in
he dumped you're guessing against the
jazz when he got blown out by 30.
no no no no i don't think he played
yesterday i'm talking about the game he
played in he dunked gabby
here's a question for you here's a
question for you i where is
show us you know we know you have the
handy dandy ipad we need to see the
handy dandy iphone where's the ticket
where's the futures on your phone
it doesn't have one the iphone's right
here the iphone is right there
so crazy hold on timeout time out what's
so
crazy and mind-blowing to me is when i
met you
you told everybody you didn't bet but
you're trying to pray
paint this picture that i don't bet bro
everybody in the comments know that i
bet
girl kelly knows that bosses knows that
i bet
great just want to see the next ticket
yes exactly greg
we invented the worst bra betters of all
time bracket because of you
because you're the dude who doesn't bet
he invented that for you
you guys didn't invent that for me you
guys invented that for her
hopefully that's the right way yeah that
for her you
are right you are the guy that doesn't
bet my job that's not true
that is cabbie that is absolutely lovely
i mean listen
about this bet greg does bet but i know
for a fact greg does not have a net's
futures bet that's the difference i've
seen greg bett
we sat at a casino for an entire year
together i know now
but i know for a fact he does not have a
nets futures ticket
all right well i i would love to i would
still love to see it because i said hey
i know for a friend and you showed up
and guess what guess what cabbie i know
for a fact kelly you owe me 500
we are going to get to that we are going
to get to that listen in the last
in the last 10 years uh eight of
eight players who won the nba's most
improved player have become
bona fide leaders of their teams this
list includes
yana santa tecumpo victor oladipo
jimmy butler it includes paul george
and brandon ingram with the success of
the new york knicks
squarely on his shoulders julius randle
is now the betting favorite to win the
nba's most valuable player
watch him work yes i love the step back
with the left
too he's a batman
and this guy's this guy's leading the
nba in minutes played because
tom typical that was a huge jam by the
way
tom thibodeau's like i'm just gonna run
you into the ground the way we did
derek rose years ago with the chicago
poles there is
julius randle minus 130 on top of the
board
jeremy grant for detroit plus 125 having
a great season
christian wood plus 1400 he's missed 17
games
with due to injury but there's a lot of
there's a
he's a long shot jalen brown with the
celtics uh g-money
we know that you are our most improved
player uh but what do you need from the
audience
hey uh i need the audience to get in the
comments
tell me who you think uh should win
this year's most improved player just
keep it very simple tell me who you
think should win this year's most
improved player i don't have no idea
what cabbie means i'm the most improved
but kelly you've got your take if
anything if anything cabbie you're the
most improved bro you went from not
betting to barely betting
so put it in i guess one of the two beds
caddy is the most improved player but
not because of that because cabbie
actually absorbs things and listens
and is trying to become a better better
you just
blatantly throw egregious five-team
parlays
vegas right i've seen this before on
some documentary before that's how you
bet and that's how you lose long-term
yeah keep putting those minus four
hundred dollar
money lines carla's i dare you this is
how
this is how you're the most improved
greg because it when you play collegiate
baseball
your batting average was somewhere like
by like the orlando magic winning
percentage
but then when we had a bets you actually
connected on some of those 90 mile an
hour
basketball so that's how you're the most
improved
you went from not hitting anything in
college you're hitting a couple out here
in vegas cabbie you are hilarious
brother
don't talk about the last time we went
to the backhand we don't want to talk
about that but
no i won i won the last time i did that
you you cheated
we did gabby you cheated your way i
would have loved to add a real picture
line up against greg like a real
collegiate pitcher that'd been let's do
anything
let's do it max producer max let's do it
say less okay so kels who is who is your
most improved player in the nba this
season let's bring back up the list i
want everybody to see this so
julius randle no disrespect for him look
you guys just showed the video exactly
why
but let's go down towards the bottom
with zach levine 36-1
averaging over 28 points a game helping
out his teammates kobe white and
thaddeus young
this is the most improved bulls team
we've seen in a really long time
why because my dude zach levine
cosign i'm right there with you kel's
chicago is only two and a half games
back from the new york knicks
they're currently ninth in the nba
chicago's almost has
as many wins this year as it did last
year and there are still
30 games to play and that's because of
the first time all-star
zach levine 28 points five assists
five rebounds the guy is shooting the
lights out 44
from downtown he's been a monster and
the last chicago bull
to average 28 five and five
yeah that chicago bowl that's the kind
of season that
zach levine's been having that's the
that's the m.i.p
at plus 3600. g-money who do you like as
who do you see yourself as in the nba
uh if i was nba player i would be
definitely be draymond cavie i'm
draymond
i'm finding my shooters i am finding
shooters
playing elite perimeter defense and
also if we take it to the block i gotta
hand up on you
uh you know
greg is about a foot and a half shorter
than draymond green
don't go ahead and say that no way
possible okay
it is okay he asked the question and i'm
answering it
it is also you also have the confidence
of draymond green
so okay but on this list on this betting
list
uh with randall demonta sabonis uh
jeremy grant
who do you like as the most valuable
player most improved player excuse me
gabby we played his video at oh actually
you know what before i even i
accidentally almost told you guys what i
was going to do
i'm in the comments cabbie and it's a
runaway it is absolute a runaway i see a
bunch of uh julius randle
but uh i just want to talk about um
kelly pan me because that's what i see
in the comments as well i got how many
feet says kelly paid my man greg already
shouts out to you how many feet you are
walking away with a hoodie joe yan's in
the comments says pay
greg shouts out to you joe diana right
you're also walking away with a video
coupon story with mikey the other day
when i said
if greg hits this parlay i'm gonna find
a new job
so mikey can attest to that but we're
gonna get to that here in a minute
because that is some bs greg you're
parley
tonight can i finish it can i finish
mikey was so mad at you where's mikey
locks in the comments can i
finish it cooked into pay the men kelly
thank you cupton uh i'll give away some
julius random
uh randall's uh in fluger said julius
randle do what game says julius randle
d-g-h-e-r says julius randle uh
and matt dodger 23 says pay-up kelly so
uh
i'm rocking with i'm right hey hey cabby
you know what i like to do i'm rocking
with
i'm rocking with the squad i'm rocking
with the squad julius randle we played
his video
at the beginning of the segment for a
reason
he's been going absolutely crazy this
year shout out to my guy he's he's i
think he's the favorite for a reason man
so just
right he's been he's been tremendous and
also a first-time all-star so salute to
the next i'm
it was probably because the most of our
audience is in the northeast but you
know and actually
you know that's the first time we've
ever spoken about the knicks in the
group chat
but uh salute to you guys at uh 22 and
22.
um listen today the buyout market
the trade market the roach bombs the
shams
shams bombs kelly's basically tried
everything
to trade lonzo ball for greg ivory but
greg ivory comes with a considerable
uh cap hit and a 500 bet
yes sir friends is a national pastime
but sometimes it ends friendships uh
greg
finally broke his 12-week losing streak
by hitting a
five-legged game from parliament minus
140
minus 140 again vegas greg
needs to go sell his whale plays in
mexico
get himself a fake girlfriend and
pretend like he's doing big things
because that is how fake
this parlay is you might be on to
something you might have just started
something
this is obviously highly contentious
between
greg and kelly because there's 500 bucks
on the line
so just be just to be perfectly clear
happy camping
time out right now i'm gonna go ahead
and say this 500
500 whatever i will venmo you 500
dollars right now
i know greg needs the money to pay his
new jaguar payment but it's not about
actually it's about the duel it is the
principle
of the bet i actually do need that 500
kelly i know you do i i know you know
listen hold on listen listen just so
just so that the audience
is has caught up to speed and just so
that we're clear on the terms
let's take a look at this magical moment
from 14 weeks ago
when the bet was first created
i'm actually guaranteeing that we win at
least
one of these this season guarantees why
would you do that
great great great great greg first of
all now you just jinxed yourself
way to go second of all i will bet you a
nickel
500 real american dollars none of that
stuff from
where cabbies from real american dollars
that you do not hit one of these
five leg same team
parlays it's not gonna happen i'm sorry
you're not gonna do it
kelly guess what you got yourself a bet
[Music]
we have ourselves a bet and after 35
weeks
of misses greg gained the system and he
finally got a w
so you guys are the jury in the comments
section
here is the question should kelly have
to pay
greg for for hitting the negative odds
five game parlay as kelly said it was
minus 140
it was sorry uh it was it's -140 right
oh yeah let's let's take a look at the
uh at the ticket
fifty dollars to win 35
minus 143 this is the ticket last week
i love seeing those green check marks
but um
oh yeah there it is there it
look i know we put up some really dumb
tickets like ten things to win nine
things and
ridiculous things but under no
circumstances was this even a real
ticket because we know greg didn't
actually put it in
two tickets minus 143 22-1
five teamers paid 22-1 you know why i
had to look that up because i've never
in my life ever said i'm gonna go to the
window and bet a five
teamer because they don't hit greg
that's the point if you were gonna cheat
and say i'm gonna lay minus three
dollars minus four dollars
i'm letting you get it out get it out
i'm gonna get it out
they can they can go ahead and they can
tell you all day that you deserve to get
it but you did not hit a five team or
you hit
oh yes the biggest greg ticket that is
bogus
no you want to see what i hit hey pull
it back up brett pull it back up let me
show you what i hit kevin where's that
let me show you guys
what was the juice go ahead put the
ticket back up but show me when we get
the ticket back up every single one of
those bets
thank you every single one thank you
there it is 400 cj's today
this is this is 250. bam out of bio
this is today this is today that's the
one
that's it that's it right there show me
what please wait show me
exactly which one of those was plus
money can i show you one of those
one of those can i ask you one question
one of them can i
can i ask you one question do you see a
red x on that
on that ticket i don't see it red x is
i'm going to read this to you from our
director who's our director
who he's talking about our producer what
do you think is it max
is our producer i don't know you
definitely shouldn't pay him on that
win i'll leave it he goes as much as i
love the content
i wouldn't either wait okay hold on hold
on hold on
hold on hold on craig he said that
i'm like right i need you i need you i
need you to present your case
to the audience so that the jury
can then decide who like should kelly
pay the 500
or not so present your case so listen
look look
when you go to court you know you
present facts and facts only
yeah but when you have a journey it's
supposed to be hold on counselors
talk during kelly's time uh ordering the
court
ordering the court ordering the court
here we go
here we go when you go to court court is
based off of
soul facts and you kelly
you cabbie the producers the tech team
everybody in the comments
just saw what happened back when we made
the bet
and guess what we just threw the graphic
up and then you saw five check marks
some were almost equal to a five team
parlay but most of them in the eights
the nines
there's no pay hit there's no money
parlay
listen if you think you're that good
don't learn nothing you think you're
that good double or nothing
i'll give you a dime but you gotta have
some clear parameters because you cannot
just say
oh yeah fine i can go bet alabama
moneyline
oregon moneyline during football
if you want a double or nothing pay me
my money then we can double or nothing
how about
that double or nothing works okay so
what do you mean
a
hold on i'm typed in with some of the
commenters jay
one two three three two one says if you
don't pay greg then he'll go bankrupt
nick cavallo 26 says pay greg joe yan
says this max guy is a hater
how many feet says just take your l and
pay my boy greg
and uh finally uh phillyfan21 just says
hey so that's where some of the
um some of it and then mikey locks is
chimed in
mikey lotsa said uh sad that our family
is splitting apart over 500
over 500 that's what i'm saying man you
guys make big bucks
y'all make the big bucks and it's 500
kelly come on
i'll double or nothing but just pay off
right now don't worry wait oh my
god you can't go double or nothing and
then say pay me what do you mean
five hundred dollars oh that's it oh we
lifting
it's good it's good we're the vegas
after this
it's good i'm done doing the show i told
mike if i have potatoes i'm done doing
the show
so anyway i'm gonna go do locky town
with mikey no we're done
no we're done here i'm no way cows i
wait pat boninelli you're walking away
with hoodie do what game you're walking
away with it
nick you're up nick caravillo you're
walking away with a hoodie
m go blue chip cheese down to earth
uh two man pics everybody i say you're
walking away with a hoodie
because uh they all said team greg
before and hey listen
thank you to our jury our jury pool for
for signing for making a decision in
this
this case which is tearing our family
apart kel's i'm not going to let you
leave the group chat
we have to look at uh g-money's
five-legged same-game parlay this week
and i wish i could hold on to your leg
because mommy's not leaving so what do
we got for this week greg i know you
like
portland versus miami some trades were
made so some some players aren't playing
salute to norm powell going to portland
uh jimmy butler is not in the lineup
tonight olynyk is going to houston
victor oladipo is going to miami
uh avery bradley's going to anyway
tonight what do you got my friend
in the seven o'clock game portland at
miami
cabbie and kelly
thank you for that kelly i really
appreciate that you really don't know
how much that means
oh i know how much you needed it it's
okay oh i really don't know what you
want
that's you're trying to make it a joke
but i'm not i really do need it y'all
make the big bucks i don't
so i really do need the 500 i really do
need that
jaguar payment will not be made let's
get to the parlay let's get to the
parlay here we go
we're starting off with robert covington
robert
comington let's go get off with robert
covington
to score 10 points just go get 10 go get
10 man that's easy go get 10.
moving on to my guys cj mccollum cavi
yeah let's get let's get it cj come on
cj go out there and ball for me man i
just need 20 points
20 kevin 20 from cj yeah 20 20 20 from
cj
listen if there's no jimmy butler then
you have a good shot at that
no jimmy butler you know no no gary
trent jr he got traded no rodney hood he
got traded
the ball is going to be in their hands
and and going on to the next pick or the
next leg of this parlay we're going to
rock with dame lillard
dame lillard to score over 30. 30. go
drop 10.
that's possible that's possible that's
dang because you know
if it's game time it's dangerous and
guess what kelly that was a plus play
all these are plus plays by
by the way anyway and it won't happen
and a bio
that's my whole fam's whole time but
that's cool you got
listen you found a loophole i'm proud of
you how about next week we have you do
it and see if it hits
i mean i would actually put in the bet
and spend the time and not take a bunch
of overs but hey that's okay
yeah yeah yeah sounds good here we go
bam mata bio
bam mata bio over 12 rebounds go grab em
bam go grab them thanks bam and then we
go end it off cabbie we go end it off
with kendrick none just gonna make two
threes kendrick
two threes okay i like this let's pop
through this part two
i like this one i might i might uh i
might jump in on i might tell you on
this parlay too
let's see the ticket yeah you tell me
kathy this is actually gonna win four
thousand dollars
four look at that look at that right
there you quick fo bands
that's like you fouling your taxes
that's like file attack is a quick phone
you feel me
quick fi
[Laughter]
quick phone right there off the off the
same game parlay man
that one looks pretty good man i mean
bam's gonna have room to put enos kanter
even though he doesn't play defense he
swallows up a ton of rebounds i think he
had a 19 and 19 game
earlier this week so that might be the
one spot
in the parlay that uh that might that
may not
uh may not hit but i like i like the
ticket kells you like that five this
five-legger
i like that it actually pays 40 to one
like a five-team plus moneyline parlay
should like the one i gave to you guys
on friday that's how that was supposed
to be
that was hidden that was hidden but that
was your first parlay in like
the two three years i've been working
with you that i've seen you hit
so i've hit i didn't hit it utah state
choked it up in the second half oh so it
didn't my point
i hit like six of them since i worked at
bleacher report it didn't hit but at
least
it had an opportunity to do so and
that's what i'm saying
look bottom line lisa's wireless pays 40
to 1.
i'm just sitting here still reading the
comments i love you i love you kelly
what's your love
uh g-money you wanna you wanna give away
some hoodies before we get out yeah man
yeah let me give away to let me give
away some hoodies easymoney98
he says i have kendrick nunn it's a lock
and a half shout out to you uh philly
fan 21 his car is going to get repo'd if
she don't pay up
wow philly finn that's that's that's
that's true
i just gave him a five that's that's the
thing he's not lying that's that's see
that's the thing
like he's not lying i need that money uh
we got
l davis greg paid to uh paid you your
500. greg's paid too oh i see what you
said greg's pay too you're 500
shout out to you l davis you're walking
away with a hoodie uh
not luca doncic not luca doncic
he is uh some of these dudes are
straight clowns said team kelly man
team kelly kelly i mean come on the
people love me you like don't
don't hate i got you vegas greg you're
all good
richie 21 richie 21 you're also walking
away with a hoodie
vegas greg give me the name i guess
i'm just going to salute you pay up
kelly pay up kelly in the comments
salute to payoff kelly salute to team
greg salute to vegas greg and salute to
all of you
who tapped into the group chat presented
by fanduel thank you so much uh for
joining us remember what you learned
here today
always read the fine print of any bet
you make
with your friends the three by tuesday
is available tuesdays and thursdays from
fanduel
and uh if you lose a bet pay up
immediately as
kelly kells did so alongside kelly
stewart and greg ivory my name is cabbie
richards
we're leaving the group chat and we're
going to try to resolve our family
issues off camera
take care guys peace
[Music]
you